رغم محاولاته طهران الى عمليه انصهار اكثر
منه تماهن بين الميليشيتين التشابه
والمحاكاه العلاقات الحوثيه لا تقتصر على
ميليشيا ايران المفضله بل تمتد الى
ميليشيات طيران ايضا في العراق ادرج
الحوثيون عددا من ميليشياتهاما في الهيكل
الاداري لوزاره الدفاع سعيا خلف غطاء
شرعيا لتنظيم غير شرعي وبطبع لدفع الاجور
وبعيدا عن المعارك يظهر التعاون بين اذرع
ايران في مجالات اخرى كالاعلام التمويل
والدبلوماسيه في 2019 استغل الحوثيون
اذاعه المحليه تدعى سام اف ام لاطلاق حمله
تبرع لحزب الله تحت عنوان مبادلات الوفاء
بالوفاء والحمله جمعت 130,000 دولار
والعبره هنا ليست بالرقم
وحتى في تشابه المصطلحات وخطابات نصر الله
والحوثي وخلفيه الكروما الاخراجيه وتخصيص
شعار لكل مناسبه تشابهن منطقي بما ان
قناتي الساحات والمسيره الحوثيه تبثاني من
بيروت الحقيقه ان اهتمام النظام في طهران
بسلاح الاعلام ليس جديدا وصفه خامنئي
بالسلاح الاقوى فهو يرى فيه جزءا لا يتجزا
من نهج تصدير الثوره بعد عام واحد من
سيطرته على البلاد وتحديدا في عام 1980
اطلق اذاعه جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه
خدمتها الى اليوم ويختار المرشد الايراني
رئيس الاذاعه كما توفى المدينه الضاحيه
الاعلاميه كما يطلق عليها التدريب والدعم
الفني واعداد المحتوى وهو ما يفسر تكرار
عبارات الاعلام الحربي في مقاطع فيديو كل
من حزب الله الحشد الشعبي
وقوات النظام السوري
[موسيقى]